so you think women would be more
attracted to a man in a relationship
even if they didn't know that they were
in a relationship yeah a lot of young
men have this experience right that no
women pay attention to them for a long
time until they get a girlfriend they
get a girlfriend suddenly they're
getting sexual validation romantic
validation and suddenly other women are
paying attention to them and they don't
even know what changed in biology that's
called mate Choice copying when females
are more attracted to a male that's
valued by other females and I think
that's kind of mediated by sexual
self-confidence if a man has a
girlfriend already he knows at least
there's one woman out there who values
me and he kind of internalizes that
validation and then like radiates it
outwards somehow and then other women
pay attention to that